the Donald Trump Republican tax bill
will be law before you know it the House
of Representatives voted to pass it the
US Senate has voted to pass it the House
of Representatives then had to do sort
of a procedural revote because of some
minor almost like clerical changes to
the Senate version and of course the
House and Senate both have to sign the
exact same legislation and Donald Trump
is expected to sign it but maybe today
very soon I don't know how soon but it's
gonna happen pretty quickly so it is
happening it is a disaster and we will
do a full analysis of the final bill and
its provisions tomorrow because
throughout this entire process what's
actually in the bill has been a bit of a
mystery even as we found out yesterday
to some of the people signing the bill
who decided that they were in favor of
the bill even without total familiarity
with what was in it and what's been
interesting to see is how the closer the
bill has become the closer the bill has
gotten to becoming the law the more
opposition there has been from the
American public which is different
because usually the American public
likes quote tax cuts as a general thing
when you cut people's taxes people tend
to like it even though yeah some people
have questions and concerns about the
economic viability of it but this is not
the case in this particular instance and
I'm gonna give you the polling number in
a moment and part of what's going on
here is that the public does not believe
it is actually a tax cut for them then
being most people not corporations in
the very very rich most people didn't
want this bill to pass and I would even
say that if more people understood the
bill and understood what the bill does
the numbers would be even more lopsided
in opposition to the bill so we have
this new CNN poll conducted by SSRS and
it shows that opposition to the bill
is up 10 percentage points since the
start of November 55% of the country now
opposes the bill also from this poll
two-thirds of the country believes that
the bill does more to benefit the
wealthy well yeah that's true that's an
accurate assessment from two-thirds of
the people in this country 37% of the
country believes that their family will
be worse off under the bill
if by paying higher taxes you're worse
off than that's at least 37% really over
the long term more than half of all
Americans will pay more taxes under this
plan sixty-three percent of the country
believes that Trump and his family will
personally be better off under the bill
that's true the fact that only 63%
thinks that tells us a lot of people
don't really know what's in the bill
73% say that Trump should release his
tax returns to the public I agree and we
are not going to see those probably ever
I would say dr. Howie not gonna happen
89% of Democrats oppose the bill 76% of
Republicans support the bill so a huge
split between Democrats and Republicans
here but there's no doubt that big
picture overall in the balance in the
net opposition to this bill has grown
over time and that tells us a lot about
why they've been so eager to pass this
thing so quickly even without reading it
themselves in the House and Senate pass
it before public outcry grows even more
pass it before Doug Jones is seated in
the Senate although in this case a
straight party-line vote they would have
actually been able to pass it anyway
after Doug Jones was seated that's true
yeah and maybe it's an appeal to
popularity to say that this bill is
unpopular therefore it's bad policy but
we live in a government that's supposed
to represent the people right and all
the people not just the rich and the
corporation's yeah I think that's what's
telling here I'm not saying that it's a
bad bill because people are opposed to
it although I believe that a lot of
people are opposed to it because it is a
bad bill but what I am saying is that if
we have a representative democracy here
why wouldn't the will of the people be
reflected in how our elected officials
are voting so as a good distinction and
point that pat pat pat is making here so
we've got to realize that bottom line
the desires of the people are not being
reflected in our government at every
level to go back a few months at the
election level right millions more
people voted for Hillary Clinton than
for Donald Trump yet Donald Trump is
president due to the Electoral College
does that reflect the will of the people
or does it reflect the system that's
designed in a very particular way as
system that can be taken advantage of
most Americans are in favor of net
neutrality yet it was repealed Americans
overall believe climate change is real
and caused by humans but the White House
has made the United States the one
country that is not going to participate
in the Paris climate Accord so there's
this very very long list an opposition
to this tax bill is now part of that as
well it's truly sad and there's only one
path forward pad I'm sure you know what
I'm going to say I've been saying it for
weeks now what does the vote them out
vote them out we have to vote them out
that is the only path forward because
they they are not even doing your will
if the American people wanted this stuff
I would disagree with it but at least
I'd say it reflects the will of the
people
none of this reflects the will of the
people the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership